THINGS, CHAD.
YOU GET AN "A" FOR THE DAY.
HE’S BEEN ALL OVER THIS.
EVERYTHING HAS TO GO LIKE
CLOCKWORK FOR REPUBLICAN
SENATORS HOPING TO MAKE A
JUSTICE AND I WILL ALL STARTS ON
THURSDAY.
"THE FIVE" IS NOW.
>> HELLO, EVERYONE, IT’S FIVE IN
NEW YORK CITY AND THIS IS "THE
FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLEASHING IN
HIS FIERCEST SUPPORT YET OF HIS
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I CAN TELL YOU
THAT FALSE ACCUSATION AND FALSE
ACCUSATIONS OF ALL TYPES ARE
MADE AGAINST A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THIS IS A HIGH QUALITY PERSON,
AND I CERTAINLY HOPE, I -- IT
WOULD BE A HORRIBLE INSULT TO
OUR COUNTRY IF THIS DOESN’T
HAPPEN.
AND IT WILL BE A HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE THING FOR FUTURE
POLITICAL PEOPLE, JUDGES,
ANYTHING YOU WANT.
IT WOULD BE A HORRIBLE THING.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING A
CON GAME.
C-O-N, A CON GAME.
AND THEY KNOW IT’S A CON GAME.
THE ACCUSER HAS NOTHING, SECOND
ACCUSER DOESN’T EVEN KNOW -- SHE
THINKS MAYBE IT COULD HAVE BEEN
HIM, MAYBE NOT.
SHE ADMITS SHE WAS DRUNK.
SHE ADMITS TIME LAPSES.
HE’S STARTLED.
HE CAN’T BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING.
HIS WIFE IS DEVASTATED.
HIS CHILDREN ARE DEVASTATED.
I DON’T MEAN THEY ARE LIKE, OH,
GO, I’M A LITTLE UNHAPPY.
THEY ARE DEVASTATED.
>> MEANWHILE, SENATE DEMOCRATS
ARE CONTINUING TO PROVE THAT THE
FACTS DON’T MATTER WITH A NEW
WAVE OF SUMMERS AGAINST
KAVANAUGH.
>> THE SECOND THING ABOUT THAT
INTERVIEW IS WHEN HE SAID THAT
HE ACTUALLY DOWNPLAYED HIS
DRINKING AND HE SAID HE NEVER
REALLY BLACKED OUT SO HE DIDN’T
REMEMBER THINGS.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT REALLY GO
TO CREDIBILITY GIVEN SOME OF THE
STORIES CIRCULATING OUT THERE.
>> I’VE HEARD FROM BOTH SIDES
AND I BELIEVE DR. BLASEY FORD,
AND I BELIEVE MS. RAMIREZ, BOTH
OF THEIR STORIES ARE CREDIBLE,
UNLIKE HIS.
HE WOULDN’T ACTUALLY ANSWER THE
QUESTION OR SAY WHY HE WOULDN’T
BE INTERVIEWED BY THE F.B.I.
THAT’S NOT THE RESPONSE OF
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO PLEAD HIS
INNOCENCE.
>> IT IS JUDGE KAVANAUGH WHO IS
SEEKING A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT
TO THE SUPREME COURT AND HE
BEARS THE BURDEN OF DISPROVING
THE ALLEGATIONS RATHER THAN DR.
FORD AND MS. RAMIREZ, WHO SHOULD
BE DISMISSED WITH SLANDEROUS
ACCUSATIONS.
>> DANA: GREG, I’M GOING TO
START WITH YOU, YOU’RE A GOOD
PLACE TO START.
THEY ARE THROWING OUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THAT
IS THE RIGHT OF CONFRONTATION,
THE RIGHT OF CROSS-EXAMINATION,
SENATORS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY MADE UP THEIR
MIND.
THEY HAVE HEARD FROM HER, THEY
HAVE HEARD FROM HIM SO WHAT’S
THE POINT OF HAVING COURTROOMS
AND TRIALS IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHOULDN’T WE JUST DECIDE IF WE
LIKE SOMEONE AHEAD OF TIME?
GREG: WHAT’S INTERESTING IS THEY
ARE BEING HONEST ABOUT IT NOW.
BOTH COONE AND -- BOTH HAVE
FORMULATED A FAIRLY CHILLING
RESPONSE WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT DUE
PROCESS.
THEY GO, THIS ISN’T A COURT OF
LAW.
YOU DON’T NEED A DUE PROCESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY ARE RIGHT.
THEY ARE BASICALLY ADMITTING
THAT WE CAN CRUCIFY YOU WITHOUT
EVIDENCE OR ANY KIND OF
CORROBORATION BECAUSE LET’S KEEP
IT OUT OF THE COURT OF LAW AND
SO YOU LOSE -- WHAT YOU LEARN
NOW IS YOU LOSE YOUR RIGHTS IF
YOU’RE UP FOR A JOB, SO MY
SOLUTION IS EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
GET ACCUSATION INSURANCE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW, THOUGH IT’S TRUE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING IS.
>> IT’S CALLED GO FUND ME.
GREG: YOU’RE GOING TO NEED
ALLEGATION INSURANCE AND THE
THING IS, ONE LAST POINT, JUDGE.
WE AS HUMAN BEINGS WE MIMIC
BEHAVIOR, IF YOU LOOK AT
FASHION, DIET, SOCIAL MEDIA, WE
COPY EACH OTHER.
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR WILL
SPREAD.
THE EXCEPTION OF SIMPLY AN
ALLEGATION MINUS EVIDENCE IS
GOING TO SPREAD INTO OTHER AREAS
OF OUR CULTURE.
IT’S ALREADY HAPPENING.
YOU SEE IT IN THE WORKPLACE AND
OTHER PLACES.
HOW DO WE STOP IT?
JUDGE: KENNEDY, HOW DO WE STOP
IT?
WHAT WE’VE GOT IS, UNITED STATES
SENATORS SAYING THAT HE NEEDS TO
DISPROVE A NEGATIVE.
HOW DO YOU DISPROVE OR PROVE A
NEGATIVE?
HE’S GOT TO DISPROVE HE DID
THIS.
IF HE WASN’T THERE AND HE DIDN’T
DO IT, NUMBER ONE, HOW DOES HE
PROVE THAT?
AND NUMBER TWO, HOW CAN UNITED
STATES SENATORS SHIFT THE BURDEN
OF PROOF.
IT’S ALWAYS THE COMPLAINANT.
>> IT’S SMART WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY ARE COMING UP WITH A SERIES
OF DEMANDS THAT ARE ALMOST
UNMEETABLE, AND SO ESSENTIALLY
WHEN REPUBLICANS ON THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SAY WE CAN’T
MEET THOSE BECAUSE THEY DON’T
MEET THE STANDARD FOR, YOU KNOW,
PROTOCOL IN THE SENATE, BUT
ALSO, I MEAN, THAT’S HOW OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, THAT’S
WHAT IT’S BASED UPON, WHICH
ESSENTIALLY FOLLOWS FROM NATURAL
LAW.
SO YOU’RE TURNING ALL OF THAT ON
ITS HEAD AND YOU CAN’T DISPROVE
A NEGATIVE.
JUDGE: COMMON-LAW, ABSOLUTELY.
KENNEDY IS RIGHT, JESSE BUT THEY
ARE SAYING SHE’S NOT GETTING
FAIR AND RESPECTFUL TREATMENT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> JESSE: I THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN UNFAIR AND DISRESPECTFUL
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE PROCESS,
TO KAVANAUGH WITH THE SMEARS AND
SANDBAGGING.
LISTEN, EVERYTHING THEY HAVE
DONE HAS BEEN POLITICAL, THE
TIMING, THE DEMANDS, THE
ENTOURAGE SURROUNDING THIS
PERSON.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE REPUBLICANS
SAID?
THEY SAID OKAY.
LET’S TAKE POLITICS OUT OF IT.
WE AREN’T GOING TO QUESTION HER.
WE’RE GOING TO APPOINT AN
INDEPENDENT SEX CRIMES
PROSECUTOR, FEMALE, WHO KNOWS
WHAT SHE’S TALKING ABOUT, AND
SHE’LL BE THE ONE TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS, NOT THE POLITICIANS,
AND THEN THE DEMOCRATS TURN
AROUND AND SCREAM AND SAID, THIS
IS UNFAIR.
THIS IS GOING TO CREATE A
CIRCUS.
THEY HAVE BEEN THE ONES CREATING
THE CIRCUS HERE, AND THIS TYPE
OF PERSON HAS BEEN USED BEFORE.
IN WATERGATE, IN IRAN CONTRA AS
WELL AS MAFIA HEARINGS SO THERE
IS NOTHING NEW TO THIS.
JUDGE: BRINGING IN AN OUTSIDE
ATTORNEY.
>> THERE IS NOTHING NEW TO THIS
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
COMPLAINING BECAUSE I DON’T
BELIEVE FORD WILL LOOK GOOD
BEING QUESTIONED BY A FEMALE
EXPERIENCED LITIGATOR WITH THE
STORY THAT SHE HAS.
I THINK HER STORY WILL NOT HOLD
UP WELL, AND THAT’S THE REASON
THE DEMOCRATS ARE UPSET ABOUT
THIS.
>> I HAVEN’T HEARD A WORD HERE
THAT INDICATES -- BECAUSE THE
JUDGE STARTED OUT BY SAYING
DEMOCRATS ARE SMEARING JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
I HAVEN’T HEARD A WORD OF SMEAR.
JUDGE: HE’S GUILTY.
HE’S GUILTY.
THAT’S A SMEAR.
>> THAT’S NOT A SMEAR.
>> ATTEMPTED RAPIST, THAT’S A
SMEAR.
>> LET ME TALK AND THEN YOU CAN
RESPOND.
CLEARLY THIS IS NOT A COURT.
THIS IS A SENATE CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
JUDGE: IT’S CONGRESS.
>> YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE JUDGE TO TESTIFY, TO SAY
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
NO ONE HAS HEARD FROM MS. FORD
YET.
[TALKING AT ONCE]
>> THE SECOND THING TO SAY HERE
IS, THEY ARE BRINGING IN A WOMAN
LAWYER BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOT 11
MEN ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
AND THEY ARE EMBARRASSED.
JUDGE: THEY AREN’T EMBARRASSED.
>> THEY CAN WIN BUT WHAT THEY
HAVE GOT TO DO IS THEY HAVE GOT
TO GIVE HER A FAIR OPPORTUNITY.
SO WHAT HER LAWYERS HAVE SAID
IS, HEY, WAIT A SECOND.
WE’RE NOT COMING IN HERE TO BE
BEATEN UP BY SOMEBODY WHO IS A
CRIMINAL DEFENSE INVESTIGATOR.
YOU REFUSE TO EVEN HAVE THE
F.B.I. INVESTIGATE.
JUDGE: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
THE RULES ARE VERY SIMPLE.
>> BY AN EXPERIENCED PROSECUTOR.
>> THEY ARE THE SENATORS, WHY
SHOULDN’T THEY DO THE
QUESTIONING?
>> DANA: BECAUSE THEY BALKED AT
IT.
>> THIS GUY WHO IS NOW HIDING
OUT, WHO SAYS THAT HE WAS
INVOLVED WITH DRINKING
ESCAPADES.
>> IF YOU LET ONE WITNESS COME
IN THEY WILL HAVE SEVEN, EIGHT,
OR NINE, AND THEN YOU’LL DRAW IT
OUT UNTIL NOVEMBER.
>> JESSE, YOU SAID A MINUTE AGO
WHY ARE THEY ARE RUSHING THIS?
>> THE ONLY REASON WHY IT’S
BEING RUSHED IS BECAUSE DIANNE
FEINSTEIN DELAYED IT.
>> IN OTHER WORDS, YOU WOULD SAY
IGNORE THE WOMAN, ESPECIALLY
AFTER SHE TAKES THE RISK --
>> YOU WANT IT BOTH WAYS.
HERE’S THE PROBLEM.
THE QUESTIONING OF ANITA HILL
WERE SO BAD AND OFFENSIVE AND WE
CAN’T HAVE A REPETITION OF THAT
IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
THE CULTURE HAS CHANGED.
THE SENATE HAS CHANGED, SOCIETY
HAS CHANGED AND WE’RE ALSO IN
THE MIDDLE OF A MOVEMENT AND WE
DON’T KNOW HOW THAT ENDS.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW THAT
PERMANENTLY CHANGES SOCIETY, BUT
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN AND ALAN
SPECTER GOING AFTER A FEMALE
WITNESS OR A FEMALE ACCUSER OR
SOMEONE WHO HAS SWORN UNDER OATH
TO TESTIFY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
THEN WHY NOT TRY IT DIFFERENTLY?
WHY NOT HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
SHOW BOATING BECAUSE WHEN
SENATORS HAVE THEIR CHANCE LIKE
CORY BOOKER, THIS IS MY
SPARTACUS MOMENT, THAT’S WHEN IT
TURNS INTO A CIRCUS AND THAT’S
WHEN PEOPLE TUNE OUT.
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS AUDITIONING.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT A
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
>> WHY NOT?
JUDGE: HOW ELSE DO WE TEST THE
TRUTH IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> BECAUSE YOU GIVE BOTH PEOPLE
A CHANCE TO SPEAK.
JUDGE: HOW DO YOU DECIDE?
>> WHETHER OR NOT IT’S A
CREDIBLE ALLEGATION AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU BELIEVE IT.
JUDGE: WHETHER IT’S A CIVIL CASE
OR CRIMINAL CASE -- THIS IS EVEN
MORE SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY IS GOING TO
BE UNDER THE RULE OF A SUPREME
COURT WITH A MAN ON IT LIKE
THIS, AND THAT’S WHY WE NEED TO
HAVE A TEST OF TRUTH.
I’M SAYING
>> YOU JUST WANT A HARD RIGHT
SUPREME COURT --
>> NO, WHAT I WANT IS THE TEST
OF CREDIBILITY.
>> BEFORE WE GO -- JUDGE: YOU’RE
NOT GOING TO WANT TO MISS "THE
FIVE" TOMORROW.
>> WE’RE MISSING ONE BIG THING.
HE SAID THERE WAS NO SMEAR.
WE HAD A GUY WHO JUST CRAWLED
UNDER A ROCK AFTER CALLING
KAVANAUGH AN ATTEMPTED GANG
RAPER AND MADE TWITTER PRIVATE.
INSTEAD OF DRIVING DEEP ON A
SPECIFIC CASE, WHAT DO YOU IS
YOU FIND A NUMBER OF SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES THAT ALONE ARE NOT
STURDY.
ONE, FORD, TWO, RAMIREZ, THREE,
YEARBOOK, FOUR, AVANETI’S
CLAIMS, THE YEARBOOK, THE OTHER
CASE HAS NO CORROBORATION, NO
WITNESS.
INDIVIDUALLY, THEY DON’T MATCH.
THEY ARE NOT STRONG.
SO WHAT DO YOU IS YOU CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT OF GUILT BY USING
THESE LITTLE THINGS.
THAT’S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING.
IT SEEMS TO BE WORKING WITH THE
HELP OF THE MEDIA.
JUDGE: IT IS WORKING BECAUSE THE
MORE COMPLAINANTS YOU BRING IN,
THE FEWER THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
TESTIFIED UNDER THE RUFLS OF
CREDIBILITY THAT WE’VE USED FROM
TIME --
>> THEY ARE WILLING TO STAND UP
AND PUT THEMSELVES -- JUDGE: IF
THEY DON’T SHOW UP WHAT DOES
THAT TELL YOU IF THEY DON’T SHOW
UP?
WHAT IF THEY DON’T?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
JUDGE: YOU KNOW WHY?